nous sommes avec allah lazare eva
bonjour et merci de répondre à france 24
vous êtes journaliste ukrainienne en
poste à paris vous travaillez pour les
demies l'hebdomadaire une semaine
ukrainienne qui publiant en ukrainien et
en anglais et vous avez co écrit gazprom
le nouvel empire est-ce que vous avez
des informations qui vous remontent du
terrain de kiev sur l'avancée des
troupes russes
battent régulièrement bien sûr
professionnellement je suis toute
l'actualité
qu'est-ce que des ce que ce pass
internat capitale est bon en temps d'une
craignant une ukrainienne aussi
également c'est d'avoir un maximum
d'informations fiables sur tout ce qui
se passe en ukraine on nous a annoncé et
clovis nous le confirme et des
explosions dans le quartier du mouloud
qui
sert et du centre ville de kiev c'est ça
annoncé un peu au nord c'est pas si près
que ça après ça dépend comment comment
vous comparer c'est peut-être comme 19e
arrondissement quelque chose comme ça
par rapport aux par rapport à l'hôtel de
ville je dirais comme ça
pour vous la prise de kiev là c'est une
question d'heures
mal apprise je ne pense pas que c'est
comme ça parce que les gens votent
résident déjà ils vont résister très
activement
c'est sûr que le 1ermai russe est mieux
armé que il a émis en munitions que
l'arménie chrétienne mais par contre là
et je préviens sont très motivés à se
défendre à autour de moi y'a plein plein
plein de gens qui sont inscrits soit on
comme volontaire au froment soit dans
les régiments de
l'autodéfense
organisé territorialement
tata de tas de démarches sont faites par
les gens pour nous compliquer au maximum
aux occupants la possibilité de
s'installer dans notre capitale donc je
ne pense pas qu'ils vont la prendre
c'est quand même la ville de quatre
millions d'habitants
est la ville est très très très hostile
aux occupants ont réussi
le plus grand danger immédiat c'est
le président zelensky qui s'adresse ou
très souvent à la nation il se dit
menacé il est la cible numéro un des
russes c'est ce qu'il dit
en tout cas comment est-ce qu'il est
perçu par les ukrainiens d'abord puisque
c'est un président qui a été élu en 2019
très largement élu il me semble et il a
été finalement peu alarmiste face à
l'avancée des russes contrairement aux
américains est ce qu'on le lui reproche
aujourd'hui
bah écoutez maintenant on essaie de se
dire que c'est voilà peut-être aimerait
avoir une autre précédent mais c'est pas
le moment de parler de ça pour nous pour
nous c'est voilà on n'a pas de notre on
esquive et prudence a
écouté jusqu'à jusqu'à maintenant il est
il a fait le nécessaire quand même quoi
peut-être pas assez rapidement peut-être
il fallait se préparer mieux je ne dis
pas qu'il était parfait mais il n'a pas
quand même trahi son pays pour l'instant
la france on l'a entendu jean yves le
drian dit qui est qu'elle est prête à
lui venir en aide on pense bien sûr à
une exfiltration
c'est ce que j'ai entendu dans son
dernier discours c'est que il souhaitait
rester avec son peuple après c'est à lui
d'appart yens de prendre ces décisions
en tout cas les occidentaux semblent
bien impuissant
les européens n'ont pas sorti
l'artillerie lourde bien que là
visiblement il le ils ciblent
directement vladimir poutine et et
sergueï lavrov ça vous inspire quoi
finalement ce manque d'ambition des
occidentaux mais ça donne le sentiment
d'une grande solitude de fait que
l'occident collectif si vous voulez un
manque de courage que poutine c'est une
personne qu'il faut arrêter uniquement
par force par les actions rapides et ce
qu'il faut faire maintenant si vous
voulez mon avis c'est couper l'accès au
swift à l'état russe donnait maximum
d'armes à l'armée ukrainienne nous aider
m militairement si vous voulez pas
mourir pour créer au moins de donner nos
les armes est aussi protégé le ciel sur
le crâne pour que les avions de chasse
russes
voilà
est-ce que la vitesse de propagation des
troupes russes vous vous étonne on va
peut-être voir la carte de
l'encerclement de de l'armée russe qui
visiblement fonce sur kiev ça ressemble
à une guerre qui est préparée d'avancé
bien sûr que c'est une guerre qui est
préparée d'avancé et là
les services de renseignement américains
l'ont dit il ya plusieurs mois déjà que
c'est une préparation bien sûr
mais c'est plus que ça vous savez la
guerre on est en guerre depuis 2014 la
guerre dure pour nous au depuis
l'annexion des cris mais c'était bien un
très sérieux et pas du tout les terres
séparatistes que disait la presse
française et autres os on a tous perdu
quelqu'un en cette guerre en s'évitant
c'est peut-être les combats d'autres
emplois qui se produisait dans le passé
mais c'était déjà une guerre donc pour
nous maintenant c'est une nouvelle phase
de la guerre dans lequel on vit depuis
huit ans
je rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
ukrainienne c'est aussi une guerre de
l'image de l'information de la
désinformation la des communiqués qui
nous parviennent chaque chaque minute
voire chaque seconde comment est-ce que
vous gérez ça comment travailler de
manière libre et certifié des
informations bah écoute et on vérifie au
maximum les informations donc on a plein
d oc moyens techniques pour vérifier
quand est ce que le vidéo a été
enregistrée
vérifiez est ce qu'elle est faux ou
falsifiés vérifier a par exemple avec
leur sur la montre de poutine quand est
ce qu il a parlé au moment qu'en vidéo
était diffusée ou deux jours avant y
compris par exemple les appels qui était
faite par les dirigeants de régimes des
marionnettes de donetsk est lougansk
pour annoncer leur demande elle a été
reconnue autant d'autres choses il ya
beaucoup de techniques qui permettent à
vérifier la fiabilité d'une formation il
faut aussi leur est coupée mais c'est ce
qu'on fait dans notre journal d'ailleurs
donc on travaille tous les talents
d'auteur par jour nos collègues aussi
les autres journalistes craignant donc
je pense que oui c'est pas facile mais
on essaie de travailler donner le
travail de qualité et on vous souhaite
beaucoup de courage et on vous lit dans
une semaine ukrainienne c'est en
ukrainien et en anglais puis votre livre
à la lazare et va à gazprom le nouvel
empire merci d'avoir témoigné sur france